the official enrollment period for the
affordable care act better known as
Obamacare goes into effect on Tuesday
October first here are the five biggest
things you need to know I think it's
important for us to recognize and
acknowledge this is working the way it's
supposed to health insurance premiums
were going up before the health care law
and Obamacare isn't going to change that
the laws biggest effect will be in the
individual market where for a lot of
people plans are likely to be
significantly more expensive than
individual market plans were before the
law even in some cases after the
application of taxpayer-funded subsidies
I think it's important for us to
recognize and acknowledge this is
working the way it's supposed to there's
no question that Obamacare's rules
forcing employers to cover employees
working more than 30 hours a week will
push companies to trim hours and create
more part-time staff and that's even
with those rules being delayed including
in one case where an Obamacare call
center made sure many of its workers
were part-timers I think it's important
for us to recognize and acknowledge this
is working the way it's supposed to the
administration has failed to hit many of
Obamacare's implementation deadlines so
far and it's likely that the laws
insurance exchanges just aren't ready
for primetime online enrollment is
definitely being delayed in at least one
state oregon and reports are surfacing
that the pricing mechanism isn't working
right in the federal exchanges i think
it's important for us to recognize and
acknowledge this is working the way it's
supposed to over the next 25 years
federal spending on major health care
programs is expected to rise from about
four point six percent of the economy
today to about eight percent of the
economy about a quarter of that rise is
specifically due to obamacare more than
anything else federal spending on
programs such as Medicare and now
Obamacare is why spending patterns for
the federal government are unsustainable
I think it's important for us to
recognize and acknowledge this is
working the way it's supposed to
Republicans in Congress have been making
a big fuss about delaying or defunding
Obamacare the Congressional options for
killing the health care law are really
limited right now there's still some
legal challenges in the works that
put a dent in the law but the smart
money is that most of Obamacare will go
into effect as scheduled